comment ces avancées avec guillaume
alors vu qu'on sait pas mais non c'est
pas vu depuis un petit moment pour
l'instance n'a pas avancé à la d'accord
mais l'avenir l'avenir nous le dira
peut-être mais pour l'instant en l'état
présent voilà je veux pas te mentir
guillaume c'est très bien pour l'instant
ça stagne
super la n'avance pas pour l'instant ça
n'avance pas on n'avance pas de quel
côté alors j'aimerais l'observance de
son côté mais
parce qu'elle a mis sur instagram tavana
me freine zone oui j'ai marqué fred zone
with love voilà donc voila
vous concernant c'est donc l'idée c'est
que serait une zone si vous enlevez six
lettres que vous changiez changé lors dé
vous en rajoutez deux ça fait amour
chacun
c'est vrai que si vous enlevez non même
si vous avez trois zones vous enlevez le
et vous enlevez le il eu un ouais vous
regardez les 2 n ouais ouais voilà ça
devrait ajouter ainsi ça fait connard
[Applaudissements]
donc je dirais que là dans le camp
ennemi un petit mot pour lui ouais j'ai
mis une photo j'ai mis une photo pour
dire aux gens qu'on se retrouve ce soir
mais froide zonhoven connais j'ai marqué
fredzone with love parce que j'aime
beaucoup guillaume et ça c'est vrai je
ne mens pas j'aime beaucoup guillot je
sais dans la fredzone mais avec plus
d'un mois
alors je veux dire que lorsque vous dire
entre john et justement ce sera le débat
de ce soir
est ce qu'une frêle zone peut se
transformer en look zone c'est la
question que je pose d'abord à delphine
delphine est ce possible alors je
réfléchis dans mais non la fesci s'est
vite parce que quelqu'un qui n'est pas
bien là
oui ça m'est déjà arrivé c'est vrai et
ben voilà donc tu vois voyez pas calmer
ça pour roger quoi franson a mis ça pour
roger parce que roger regarde ces
réseaux sociaux la propreté
roger réseaux sociaux
s'est pas non plus les gars ça va il
fait pas non plus voilà ça va très
confiant et gilles vous est-ce que vous
pensez que parce qu'avec fatou nous
falloir que ça se fasse un moment parler
du mariage ou non vous êtes toujours en
frêne zone avec le fat ou non une fois
qu'on est en france zone c'est fini à
penser que si jamais on en met en avant
parce qu'on peut démarrer par une
franson et après bifurquer à bientôt
bien sûr ce serait mieux non géraldine
non moi j'y crois pas non plus mais
c'est vrai ben abdallah passionnel zone
ou alors rien du tout ah ouais je pense
que là il est en train de se fourvoyer
pauvre il est aveugle est la dernière
banque y pense c'est que ça peut se
faire entre guillaume et delphine
[Musique]
[Rires]
je vous dise moi j'y crois aussi
j'y crois aussi voilà bah ouais très
belle bravo ben voila voila merci
friends all we love voilà
attention à ne pas donner peu d'espoir
ouais je vois son petit coeur dire que
quand on aime une personne on voit là on
aime une personne c'est un peu plus que
de l'amitié c'est à dire on apprécie
vraiment entièrement la personne n'était
pas clair d'accord mais l'abonné film
fut imaginons on va être dans la fiction
imaginons c'est complètement terminé
avec roger ouais vraiment c'est mort
finit on sait que c'est fini voilà roger
reparti avec quelqu'un de son âge
non mais c'est vrai voilà il est
tranquillement en train d'aller la
chercher
hespérides
et là vous savez que c'est qu alex hayes
et des partis pour la vie pas pour la
mort
ça va
pas vrai il aya lâche tu veux et on
adore et d'aller puiser delphine est ce
que les jeunes ignorés et là est bon il
faut parler sérieusement est-ce qu
ignorer
quel serait le pourcentage de chance
voilà que vous soyez vous savez clients
un pourcentage en sur 100 % bien entendu
je vais démarrer notre temps d'attenté
je veux démarrer est-ce que c'est 100 %
non non 90 non 1,80 non 70
non 60
non pas 60 ans mais attendez attendez ça
devient j'aime s'entendent
ça veut dire une chance sur deux une
chance sur deux oui donc non une chance
sur deux c'est normal c'est bien donc
beaucoup et voudrait dire que avec plein
d'autres personnes y aurait une fois ben
non non bah non 40% non non 30%
ah ouais c'est pas comme ça parce que je
sens que ça lui fait mal mais pas des
déchets d'origine adorent ça
l'agencé laissé le multi que sur
l'introduction
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à remettre à neuf exactement exactement
c'est ce que je dis toujours oui c'est
ce que je dis toujours il faut savoir
être brutal damman enfin non pas 20 h 10
5 non
je pense qu'on est dans les alentours de
l'ordre de peut-être 10% l'infiniment
petit et non voilà
voilà un score
correct donc une chance sur dix ne s'est
pas nulles et non non ces primes c'est
une avoir une chance sur les cinq
delphine c'est énorme désolé c'est
énorme voilà